bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur LCP à
l'ordre du jour la loi dit klope me lois
d'orientation et de programmation pour
le ministère de l'intérieur elle donne
15 milliards d'euros sur 50 aux forces
de l'ordre pour permettre notamment la
création de 8500 postes de policiers et
gendarmes après une semaine de débats en
séance publique place aux explications
de vote la séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle le vote
solennelle du projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur donc il y a un
orateur par groupe pour des explications
de vote de 5 minutes
la première oratrice ce sera madame
Blandine brocard pour le groupe
démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mais cher collègue
sans ordre républicain il n'y a ni
sécurité ni liberté
cet ordre ce sont les policiers et les
gendarmes sur notre sol qui la sûr ils
sont exposés à des risques quotidiens en
notre nom c'est pourquoi il mérite le
soutien de la puissance publique et la
reconnaissance de la Nation
ainsi s'exprimer le président de la
République dans son adresse aux Français
du 14 juin 2020
deux ans plus tard c'est ce soutien de
la puissance publique à nos forces de
sécurité intérieure que nous traduisons
ici en carnet de route pour les 5 années
à venir un soutien que notre majorité
présidentielle n'a cessé de démontrer
depuis 2017 à travers plusieurs lois
d'importance et aujourd'hui nous nous
engageons à poursuivre dans ce sens
grâce à une traduction budgétaire à
l'ensemble de ces mesures avec cette loi
de programmation et d'orientation du
ministère de l'Intérieur pour la
première fois il s'agisse de donner une
vision globale de l'action du ministère
de l'Intérieur et de ses agents qui font
un travail remarquable au quotidien au
service de nos concitoyens et nous
souhaitons tous ici j'en suis certaine
les en remercier vivement
le texte que nous nous apprêtons à
adopter portant lui une véritable
ambition afin de permettre à nos
policiers et nos gendarmes qu'ils soient
sur le terrain ou dans les bureaux ainsi
qu'à tous les acteurs du continent de
sécurité de remplir au mieux leur
mission au service de chacun de nos
concitoyens au cœur de nos territoires
il ne s'agit pas ici de définir des
objectifs sécurité mais bien de donner
les moyens humains technologiques et
financiers à nos forces de l'ordre pour
assurer leur mission
leur mission qui est de nous protéger de
protéger nos biens nos bâtiments de
protéger nos enfants de protéger notre
République
nous protéger pour permettre à tous de
vivre avec l'assurance que l'ensemble
des services du ministère oeuvre
pleinement à la sécurité de chacune et
de chacun les femmes et les hommes tous
les acteurs de cette chaîne de sécurité
méritent la reconnaissance de la nation
et de la représentation nationale
c'est pourquoi je regrette profondément
que certains dérapages et propos déplacé
la semaine passée parfois même un
ourancier et était entendu dans cette
hémicycle malgré cela nous avons pu
effectuer un véritable travail de
co-construction avec les uns et les
autres pour déboucher sur un texte qui
nous semble équilibré pragmatique et
ambitieux pour être aux avant-postes de
la sécurité de notre pays
issus de toutes les sensibilités nous
avons adopté de nombreux amendements qui
permettent de belles avancées plusieurs
amendements du groupe démocrate ont été
adoptés et nous nous en réjouissons je
pense notamment à se porter par notre
collègue Philippe la tombe en matière de
lutte contre la cybercrumilienne
criminalité des rois de Malan sur la
lutte contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles où les précisions apportées
par Laurence bischenevski dans le
rapport annexé sur la réforme de la
police judiciaire
ces garanties que nous avons inscrites
dans la loop me lors de l'examen
commission ou encore été renforcés en
séance avec l'adoption d'un amendement
du gouvernement et de notre collègue
comme vous tous ici nous serons
vigilants sur la conduite de cette
réforme et le respect des équilibre
nécessaire à la préservation de
l'indépendance de la police judiciaire
nous avons entendu vos engagements vos
assurances monsieur le ministre et nous
vous en remercions
je souhaite d'ailleurs saluer l'écoute
et l'ouverture dont vous avez fait
preuve tout au long de nos débats et qui
nous ont permis d'avancer ensemble dans
la bonne direction
j'en profite également pour vous
remercier monsieur le rapporteur pour la
qualité de votre travail
chers collègues tous ces jours passés
ensemble en commission et en séance pour
débattre de ce projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur ont été riches
d'échanges de réponse précise et de
mesure qui nous n'en doutons pas
permettront à l'institution d'être à la
hauteur des attentes de nos concitoyens
et des crises auxquelles nous pourrions
être confrontés dans l'avenir le groupe
démocrate votera avec conviction en
faveur de ce texte je vous remercie je
vous remercie
cette loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur est soutenu par une large
majorité de députés mais les réserves
sont fortes sur les bancs de la gauche
les députés de la nupesse dénoncent une
loi qui porte atteinte aux libertés et
pointe le risque d'arbitrage quel
superbe texte quelle magnifique loi
aurait pu être aurait pu être cette
locmi si l'arbre des 15 milliards
d'euros que vous y consacrez ne cachez
pas autant de carence autant
d'incertitudes de choix contestables et
de refus de votre part à l'issue de
notre travail en commission et en séance
toute la semaine dernière
il serait stupide de ne pas reconnaître
les avancées contenu dans ce texte et
notamment les formes budgétaires
importants consentis pour moderniser
notre police digitalisation numérisation
rénovation stupide aussi de ne pas avoir
en tête la vie du Conseil d'État qui a
beaucoup insisté sur la non sécurisation
de cette trajectoire budgétaire dans les
années qui viennent mais derrière
certes
8500 embauches promises de policiers et
de gendarmes mais si peu de choses sur
la formation de ces futurs agents de
l'État sur votre vision de la police
républicaine dont nous avons besoin sur
leur nécessaire connaissance approfondie
de nos villes de nos quartiers de leurs
habitants et de leurs problématiques
certes de nouveaux acteurs comme ces
assistants d'enquête censés soulager les
officiers de police judiciaire des
tâches administratives annexes mais dont
on sait que leur mission sur vous seront
finalement beaucoup plus larges
certes un accueil renforcés des victimes
de violences intrafamiliales mais aussi
votre refus de juridiction spécialisée
qui serait pourtant tellement légitime
certes beaucoup plus officiers de police
judiciaire dans les années qui viennent
mais avec moins d'expérience et formées
moins longtemps
certes une procédure pénale simplifiée
mais des garde-fous procéduro que ce
texte lève trop fréquemment
certes des amendes forfaitaire
délictuels et des plaintes en ligne
justifier dans certains cas
mais dont le principe questionne
fortement pourquoi refuser la
distinction entre atteinteaux bien et
atteinte aux personnes qui mériterait de
pouvoir bénéficier d'un débat
contradictoire devant un juge et de se
porter partie civile à force de
simplification vous frôler parfois ce
qui pourrait ressembler à une forme de
déshumanisation pourquoi persister dans
la volonté d'infliger ses amendes y
compris en cas de récidive si constitue
la preuve même qu'elles ne sont pas
toujours dissuasives
mais surtout
l'élargissement des amendes forfaitaires
individuels aux intrusions dans les
établissements scolaires et au blocage
de votre circulation pose une vraie
question démocratique au regard du droit
à manifester et à la légitimité de
l'organisation mobilisation sociale
ainsi réprimable par voie d'amende
systématique délivré immédiatement et
sans possibilité de se défendre nous
nous ont y voir une anticipation nous
nous ont y voir monsieur le rapporteur
une anticipation mais nous savons tous
ici que demain sera fait d'autres
mobilisations enfin ce texte établi un
principe sur lequel vous avez refusé de
bouger ne serait-ce que d'un centimètre
la réforme de la police nationale qui
parle biais de la départementalisation
permet celle de la police judiciaire de
la prépondérance des préfets des ddpn
dans ce domaine et de la subjectivité
des procédures au détriment des
magistrats vous y voyez une simple
question d'organisation nous y voyons un
renversement de principes majeurs majeur
et dangereux nul de citron ni les
policiers concernés bien sûr ni les
procureurs généraux ni les avocats tous
s'opposent à cette réforme porteuse de
grands risques et de grands dangers
certes également vous nous annoncez ce
que vous appelez le retour de la police
de proximité on oubliant en oubliant que
vous nous avez fait la même promesse en
2017 avec la police de sécurité du
quotidien c'est un aveu d'échec
implicite qu'il ne nous incite pas
évidemment à vous croire davantage cette
fois d'autant que vous employez
exactement la même sémantique les mêmes
arguments qu'il y a 5 ans le
commissariat doit être une exception la
présence sur le terrain doit être la
règle certes nous prenons acte de
l'adoption en commission ou en séance
d'une quinzaine des amendements que nous
avons soutenus délai de dépôt de plainte
en cas d'attaque informatique
confidentialité des plantes en ligne
élargissement des possibilités de dépôt
de plainte en dehors du domicile
circonstances AG en cas d'outrage etc
des points importants à nos yeux mais
qui sont là de suffire vous l'avez
compris c'est pourquoi Monsieur le
Ministre nous nous abstiendrons mais
vous l'avez compris il s'agit d'une
abstention extrêmement offensive
extrêmement vigilante et surtout
susceptible d'évoluer dans les jours qui
viennent en fonction du dextin que
connaîtra ce texte je vous remercie
volonté d'améliorer les conditions de
travail de la police de la gendarmerie
de la sécurité civile dans l'objectif
très transparent d'améliorer la qualité
des services rendus au public ceux de la
sécurité et ceux de la tranquillité mais
je vous le redis avec plus de fermeté
encore à l'issue de ces cinq longues
journée de délibération nous nous
opposons sur la méthode et sur
l'objectif à poursuivre
parce que sont toujours les mêmes
vieilles recettes héritées de Nicolas
Sarkozy que vous avez choisi de pimper
sans aucun travail d'évaluation sur
leurs effets au préalable de leur choix
ces méthodes je le répète sont celles de
la quantité mesuré par le nombre
uniquement le nombre de policiers le
nombre d'amendes le nombre de caméras
celle du chiffre qui conditionne
l'avancement des agents et des carrières
à l'immédiateté au détriment du temps
long des enquêtes de leur travail et de
la justice pourtant nous vous proposions
un contrat République pensez la qualité
du service rendu au public en utilisant
une double unité de mesure
l'amélioration du quotidien de nos
concitoyens et concitoyens d'un côté et
le bien-être au travail des agents de
l'autre mais c'est un mur que nous avons
reçu en guise de réponse sur
l'intégralité de l'article 1 avec une
succession de silence ou de tunnel l'un
comme l'autre visant à tuer tout débat
alors où notre pays éprouve les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
entre sécheresse super feu et canicule à
répétition cette lobby ne laisse que des
miettes pour la sécurité civile
confirmant ce que craignait les pompiers
la poursuite de l'inaction plutôt que
les mesures d'anticipation et de
résilience qui permettrait de protéger
la population des catastrophes à venir
les droits et libertés eux aussi sont
les grands perdants de ce texte les
amendes forfaitaires délictuels sont
généralisées et le risque d'arbitraire
avec elle le triplement des financements
dédiés à la vidéo surveillance est
validée sans qu'aucune étude ne vienne
confirmer une quelconque amélioration de
leur sécurité par leur implantation bien
au contraire tout concorde à l'inverse
enfin la traque des mineurs isolés a été
adoptée alors que l'interdiction du
placement des enfants ancra est refusé
ce malgré vos déclarations monsieur le
ministre en faveur de cette mesure dans
la presse
donc la fierté d'appartenir au pays des
Droits Humains abandonnés le respect des
directives internationales sur les
droits de l'enfant
nous vous avons proposé des solutions
aussi pour redonner du sens au métier
améliorer les conditions de travail des
agents en consolidant leur formation sur
le tir ou sur l'accueil des victimes par
exemple pour renforcer l'accompagnement
psychologique aussi des agents en
souffrance ou pour supprimer l'OPAC
prime de résultats exceptionnels qu'il
demande des solutions aussi pour
renforcer la confiance en améliorant
l'accueil des mineurs des victimes de
violences sexistes et sexuelles ou de
discrimination des LGBT en instaurant le
récipissé lors des contrôles d'identité
ou en réformant l'IGPN pour la rendre
indépendante et des solutions enfin pour
protéger les Françaises et les Français
des causes et des conséquences déjà
tangibles du réchauffement climatique en
renforçant les moyens de la sécurité
civile ou en instaurant une
reconnaissance effective du crime
d'écocide mais rien parmi ces mesures
qui font pourtant facilement consensus
n'a été repris tout au plus avant nous
réussit à arracher des agents formés aux
questions de violences sexuelles et et
aux violences LGBT dans tous les
commissariats pour recevoir les victimes
dignement
et puis des droits pour des pour les
citoyens pour encadrer les AFD pour que
leurs droits de recours soit connu enfin
mais ça on l'a gagné contre votre avis
des moyens pour nos campagnes vous savez
ces zones parfois oubliées de la
République avec l'expérimentation de bus
pour lutter contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes
pour les écologistes l'enjeu est clair
c'était de mettre les institutions au
service de la liberté pour la faire
respecter et pour la faire prospérer
mais le texte qui est soumis à notre
vote aujourd'hui on resterait bien la
justice en reste régnant les libertés
consacre au contraire un recul des
droits et libertés qu'aucune avancées
sur les moyens alloués aux policiers aux
gendarmes ne saurai justifier
alors effectivement nous aurions pu
co-construire nous aurions pu choisir
mieux de bleu plus de proximité plus de
sécurité plus de liberté mais non alors
parce que nous croyons et une politique
de l'Intérieur au service du public et
non des chiffres nécessaires eux
principalement au carrière le groupe
écologiste votre a contre ce texte
madame la Présidente bonsoir Monsieur le
Ministre bonsoir monsieur le rapporteur
bonsoir et monsieur le président de la
commission des lois bonsoir chers
collègues bonsoir nous votons
aujourd'hui à loop me cette loi de
programmation censée orienter la feuille
de route du ministère de l'Intérieur
pour les 5 ans à venir à travers ces 16
articles et son rapport annexés nous
avons donc un bel aperçu de ce que les
prochaines années nous réservent une
surveillance de tous les instants d'une
part
une extension à tout va de la menthe
forfaitaire de rituel d'autre part le
tout dans un contexte de relation police
population déjà dégradée monsieur le
ministre félicitations pour les crédits
très favorables que vous avez su obtenir
de Bercy c'est davantage sur votre sens
de répartition que je mettrai quelques
doutes l'un des grandes objectifs
annoncés de ce texte était celui d'un
rapprochement entre le ministère de
l'Intérieur et les citoyens je crois
pouvoir affirmer son me tromper monsieur
le ministre que votre vision de tels
rapprochement diffère sensiblement de
celle que nous combat des mortels
pouvant avoir et cela aussi bien dans sa
philosophie que dans sa mise en œuvre
parmi les principaux synonymes de ce
terme de rapprochement j'ai bien trouvé
proximité rencontre ou encore
similitudes mais j'ai eu beau chercher
je n'ai pas trouvé vidéo surveillance ni
caméra piéton et pourtant ce sont plus
de la moitié des crédit du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui seront consacrés à la
grande révolution numérique que ce
gouvernement est déterminé à mener
valorisons donc la reconnaissance
biométrique et les frontières connectées
ou encore les auditions en
visioconférence plus que la
reconstruction d'une police de proximité
bien implanté qui discute avec les
concitoyens cela voie publique qui
pratique la prévention et la pédagogie
au quotidien auprès de nos enfants qui
connaît les noms et les habitudes des
familles de nos quartiers à ce gouv
toujours aussi profond entre nos forces
de l'ordre et la population ajoutons-y
une dose supplémentaire d'arbitraire de
votre côté vous envisagez l'extension
des amendes déluelles forfaitaires comme
un élément de simplification qui
permettra aux magistrats de se
concentrer sur les affaires plus
importantes soit nous aurions plutôt une
justice automatique sans contact humain
qui relève l'empathie Oran d'une perte
de temps nous y voyons aussi une
amputation supplémentaire au droit de
chacun d'aller manifester dans la rue
pour y défendre ses convictions
maintenant ce n'est plus seulement la
crainte pour son intégrité physique qui
dissuadera le jeune étudiant qui galère
à se nourrir correctement le père de
famille qui découvre l'éco-anxiété le
livre ubereat précarisé de descendre
dans la rue
qui pour s'insurger contre la vie chère
qui pour dénoncer la violence sexiste et
sexuelle qui est pour défendre un droit
au travail effectif et non ubérisé qui
pour la lutte contre le changement
climatique qui pour demander tout
simplement à être entendu et écouter
avec l'extension des amandes
des amendes font faire délictuelles on
tapera désormais aussi au portefeuille
comme si le prix qui flamme et les
factures qui augmentent continuellement
ne faisaient pas assez déjà de dégâts au
quotidien je terminerai par une mise en
garde qui sème l'impunité récolte la
colère mais je reste sourd aux
souffrances
mais qui reste sourd aux souffrances
génère la radicalité
faux chers camarade cette loi de
programmation c'est pas vrai c'est de
votre programmation va l'encontre de
l'évolution de la France car toutes les
grandes avancées sociales sont issus du
désordre des manifestations la justice
et la paix sociale ne se sont pas
construites sur la base d'échanges
cordiaux qui l'ont que l'on aurait mené
dans un calme olympien autour d'une
table d'en bois pensé après vouloir
éloigner tout risque de désordre c'est
le sentiment d'injustice des personnes
réprimées par des mesures appliquées en
mode copier-coller qui ressortira
renforcé
le moteur de la confiance c'est
l'égalité c'est pour protester contre
l'inégalité qui transpire à travers ce
texte sur bien dévoiler que le groupe
GTR votera contre cette loi je
terminerai ce qui a pu vous paraître
comme un détail monsieur le ministre
l'arrogance teinté d'hypocrisie avec
laquelle certains amendements
ultramarins ont été confondus et balayés
au sein du rapport annexé lequel la
proton aucune valeur normative lorsque
le gouvernement annonce haut et fort que
l'outre-mer est une chance pour la
France et que la République doit
emporter les traits une telle dichotomie
entre les annonces papantes et les actes
ne pourra que vous desservir auprès de
nos populations je vous remercie
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés
nous voici donc au terme de l'examen de
la loi dite loop me au préalable si vous
m'y autorisez une remarque nous
regrettons que les débats aient été
écourtés et le travail un peu bâclé
rappelons que notre démocratie est
exigeante et que le droit d'amendement
ne serait être bafoué pour cause d'ordre
du jour trop resserré alors sur le fond
serons-nous plus en sécurité si cette
loi est adoptée c'est ça le sujet 15
milliards ils sont consacrés on pourrait
donc le penser la promotion de la
Technopolis et du continuum de sécurité
il contribue-t-il bien sûr les nouvelles
technologies peuvent être utiles comme
c'est le cas pour le réseau radio du
futur qui va enfin permettre à
l'ensemble des services de sécurité et
de secours d'être branchés sur le même
système mais comment ne pas être troublé
quand il est question d'exosquelette de
voiture augmentée et caméra infrarouge
pour surveiller nos frontières à quoi
servent tous ces gadgets nous nous lui
préférons nous leur préférons la
présence humaine et une police de
proximité ancrée au milieu des habitants
la première qualité d'un policier
n'est-elle pas son discernement le
renseignement humain n'est-il pas le
plus précieux Marc verylotte un ancien
membre du raide dans au cœur du rêve
décrit la chose suivante nul besoin de
lire l'anthologie mondiale de la
stratégie pour savoir combien le
renseignement humain est une condition
sine qua non de l'action
rien n'est indiqué sur la délinquance
financière aucun effort sur les 15
milliards de pareil être consacrés
pourtant rien que la fraude fiscale par
exemple
représenterait aux alentours dans notre
pays de 82 milliards d'euros
alors que l'on nous répète que
concernant la réforme de la police
judiciaire rien ne sera fait avant la
sortie des rapports des missions
d'information en cours au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale et aussi du côté
de l'igéa et de l'IGPN le rapport annexé
à l'article 1 évoque pourtant la
départementalisation de la police
judiciaire cela signifie un risque réel
de perte d'indépendance puisqu'elle
agira désormais sous l'égide du préfet
ce qui dessine en creux un risque réel
de dilution de leurs activités alors que
la police judiciaire agit sur le haut du
spectre des délits ça signifie quoi ça
signifie que cette réforme peut
compromettre des enquêtes qui visent au
démantèlement d'un certain nombre de
filières stupéfiants prostitution traite
d’être humain trafic d'armes qui suscite
par conséquence et si on n'agit pas à ce
niveau là du trouble des troubles à
l'ordre public et du danger pour les
citoyens bien quand on les retrouve
quand on en retrouve les conséquences
sur la voie publique comme lors de
réglement de compte ou l'insidieuse
multiplication de points de Deal au-delà
de ces profondes questions d'ordre
organisationnel n'est-ce pas dans la loi
qui trouveront une issue par voie
réglementaire ce texte est l'étendard
des fameuses procédures dites d'amende
forfaitaire délictuel AFD rappelons que
le texte initial du gouvernement viser à
les attendre à pas moins de 3400 délits
dans une logique allons à contresens de
l'exigence de l'individualisation de la
proportionnalité proportionnalité et du
sens des peines et par la même
aggraverons les inégalités devant la loi
c'est un pilier de notre procédure
pénale qui se trouve inversée on passe
de la présomption d'innocence à la
présomption de culpabilité
les délits concernés ont certes été
restreints au Sénat mais élargi dans
notre assemblée allant jusqu'à l'Impuls
par l'impulsion du groupe LR il a été
proposé et adopté une éventuelle saisie
sur les salaires des personnes
sanctionnées du NFD soyons clairs
celles-ci vise les plus précaires et les
militants il s'agit de les écarter de
l'espace public entrave à la circulation
daily filouterie dégradation légère
entrer dans un établissement sans
autorisation et nous constatons au cours
des articles et de leur examen une
érosion du pouvoir judiciaire au profit
du pouvoir administratif ce qui est en
jeu c'est la démocratie en définitive ce
texte au budget absolument faramineux ne
permet en rien davantage de sûreté pour
nos concitoyens et nos concitoyens
conformément à sa vision d'une société
qui serait en sauvagée le gouvernement
nous propose et nous le refusons
catégoriquement une orientation
sécuritaire et de surveillance massives
et une programmation gestionnaire
purement comptable pour toutes ces
raisons l'ensemble des députés de la
France insoumise Nupe voteront contre
cette loi merci
au sein de la majorité on applaudit on
salue un texte qui est l'argile le
périmètre des amendes forfaitaire
délictuelles et qui permettra aussi de
lutter plus efficacement contre les
cyber menaces
avec 15 milliards d'euros sur cinq ans
c'est un budget inédit ambitieux et
nécessaire ce budget permettra de
renforcer considérablement les moyens
humains avec la création de 8500 postes
et de 200 nouvelles brigades de
gendarmerie le doublement de la présence
policière sur le terrain permettra de
consolider la proximité de nos forces de
l'ordre avec la population
notamment dans les zones rurales et
périurbaines qui lors des quinquennat
précédent plus souffrir d'un recul de la
présence de l'État nous tenons à saluer
l'engagement du ministre d'associer les
collectivités territoriales dans la
détermination des lieux d'implantation
de ces nouvelles brigades
une preuve que la France est un pays qui
sait mettre les moyens nécessaires pour
améliorer et faciliter le quotidien le
quotidien des agents au service de
l'intérêt général la sécurité sur notre
territoire se soit avant tout des femmes
et des hommes qui ont fait le choix de
consacrer leur vie professionnelle voir
souvent une partie de leur vie
personnelle à la protection de leur père
il mérite que l'État soit à leur côté
qui leur donne les moyens d'exercer ce
métier dont ils ont tant de raison
d'être fiers grâce à des outils
efficaces et dans un environnement de
travail équilibré et ce bien sûr au
service des Françaises des Français et
de l'intérêt général grâce à des
équipements de pointe comme le réseau
radio du futur encore les tablettes néo
leur action sera grandement facilité au
profit d'une efficacité accrue dans le
rapport aux usagers plus nomades ils
pourront plus facilement aller vers les
citoyens les agents des services
d'enquête verront aussi leur charge
administratives allégées soutenu par de
nouveaux assistants d'enquêtes ils
pourront se concentrer sur leur cœur de
métier sur leur vocation
une preuve que la réponse pénale à la
délinquance du quotidien peut être
efficace et ferme trop souvent nos
concitoyens et les forces de l'ordre
elles-mêmes ont un sentiment d'inachevé
le sentiment que la réponse judiciaire
arrivant souvent trop tard ne permet pas
d'endiguer la délinquance du quotidien
c'est délinquance du quotidien est
protéiforme violence trafic rodéo
urbains la généralisation de la
procédure d'amandes forfaitaire
délictuelle permettra son nul doute de
rendre plus efficace et immédiate la
réponse pénale d'autant que la liste
limitative que nous avons défini avec
nos collègues du Sénat permet
d'atteindre un point d'équilibre qu'il
faut saluer les deux amendements
présentés par la précédente muchu
s'inscrivent totalement dans cette
dynamique sanctionner plus durement les
rodéo urbains en autorisant la
confiscation des véhicules expérimentés
la procédure d'AFD sur ce type de délit
enfin une preuve que cet assemblée peut
arriver à un compromis un compromis sain
et équilibré le technicien a été très
largement enrichi par les travaux
parlementaires du Sénat et de notre
assemblée et ce par l'ensemble des
groupes politiques je pense notamment à
la création du collège de déontologie
proposée par nos collègues socialistes
ou encore à l'amélioration de la prise
en charge des victimes de discrimination
introduit par nos collègues écologistes
nous réjouissons par ailleurs que les
idées portées par le groupe horizon et
pu recevoir un écho positif d'abord
s'agissant de la gravation des sanctions
en cas de cyberattaque conduisant à la
mise en danger de la vie de nos
concitoyens il était intolérable que la
vie des patients par exemple soit mise
en danger par les cyberattaques la loi
doit être particulièrement dissuasive à
l'égard des criminels qui alimentent
cette menace je pense bien sûr également
à la réécriture de l'article 4 imaginez
par ma collègue Anne-Laure en
concertation avec les députés
Renaissance et du MoDem cette nouvelle
écriture sécurise et encadre le système
assurantiel des renseurs tout en
s'assurant que les forces de police
puissent mener l'enquête et identifier
les le plus rapidement possible parce
qu'il faut faire que ce qui est juste
soit fort vous l'aurez compris nous
sommes convaincus que cette loi
permettra à la France d'être à la
hauteur des enjeux de la sécurité
d'aujourd'hui et de demain le gros
horizon votre a donc avec fierté et
énergie en faveur de ce texte merci
[Applaudissements]
pour le groupe prenez soin
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues aujourd'hui s'achève une
longue semaine de débat sur le projet de
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur un texte inédit
qui s'inscrit dans la traduction
concrète des engagements pris lors du
bobo de la sécurité et qui prend en
compte les besoins d'évolution
nécessaires aux forces de l'ordre et de
sécurité civile son examen en première
lecture devant le Sénat et son adoption
en forme de quasi plébiscite avec 307
voix pour et 27 contre démontre la
cohérence politique de ce texte son
souci de répondre à la demande de
sécurité exprimée par nos concitoyens et
justifie les moyens supplémentaires
alloués à nos forces de l'ordre alors
même qu'elles exercent plus que d'autres
des tâches toujours plus complexes et
périlleuses
aussi il était de notre responsabilité
en tant qu'élu de réunir l'ensemble des
conditions nécessaires au bon
accomplissement de leur mission en vue
notamment des grands événements sportifs
à venir dont l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques est paralympiques en 2024 ou
encore de la Coupe du monde de rugby de
2023 mais également pour faire face aux
nouvelles formes de menaces alors que
une entreprise sur 5 indique avoir subi
au moins une attaque par hanchen rançon
judiciaire au cours de l'année 2020
de plus ce projet de loi donne également
de la prévisibilité au travers des
moyens budgétaires inédits à hauteur de
15 milliards d'euros pour la période
2023 à 2027 confirmant ainsi les efforts
engagés à l'occasion du mandat précédent
enfin nous avons confirmé au travers de
nos débats l'ambition de ce texte en
donnant davantage de moyens à la police
et à la gendarmerie afin d'être toujours
plus présent sur le terrain mais
également pleinement engagé sur la voie
d'une simplification procédurale d'une
modernisation réelle de leurs effectifs
et de leurs moyens techniques en
modernisant leurs moyens d'action avec
le renforcement de notre politique de
lutte contre la cyber de l'incance et
des moyens de communication de
l'ensemble de nos forces de l'ordre et
de sécurité civiles en sanctionnant plus
rapidement les délits qui pourrissent la
vie quotidienne de nos compatriotes en
augmentant le nombre de délits éligibles
aux amandes forfaitaires délictuelles
au fond mes chers collègues ce texte est
la pierre angulaire de notre politique
de sécurité il est le fondement des
futurs réformes que nous porterons au
cours du mandat en effet dès la rentrée
prochaine nous aurons un débat d'un
projet de loi autour des enjeux
migratoires mais également autour de la
simplification de la procédure pénale et
je sais que ces deux textes de loi sont
très attendus comme l'ont démontré les
nombreux amendements et la richesse des
débats portant sur l'article 1 du
rapport annexé
vous l'aurez compris mes chers collègues
ce projet de loi d'orientation est de
programmation est nécessaire et le
nécessaire premier jalon des futurs
réformes structurelles qu'il revient à
la majorité la majorité présidentielle
de porter en responsabilité
avant que nous avant que nous ne votions
je tenais à souligner la grande qualité
de nos discussions en commission puis en
séance qui témoigne du travail accompli
par le rapporteur et le ministre ainsi
que de l'esprit et de responsabilité de
l'ensemble des partis prenantes qui a
présidé au travaux et à la recherche du
consensus j'en veux pour preuve
l'adoption de 181 amendements issus de
l'ensemble des groupes et notamment de
l'adoption de 73 amendements
issus des oppositions ce texte contient
des avancées qui permettront de répondre
aux attentes des forces de l'ordre et
des acteurs de la chaîne pénale mais
aussi de répondre aux légitimes
exigences de nos concitoyens qui
aspirent à une plus grande sécurité dans
le strict respect de nos valeurs et des
principes de la République aussi le
groupe Renaissance votre a donc en
faveur de ce texte je vous remercie
un autre groupe approuve les moyens mis
en oeuvre pour la sécurité il s'agit du
groupe Lyot liberté indépendance
outre-mer et territoire un groupe
composé de 20 députés qui ont une
liberté de vote mais cette fois une
majorité d'entre eux approuve le texte
de Gérard Darmanin la parole est à
Christophe negelen pour 5 minutes tout
d'abord en préambule je tenais à rendre
hommage à nos gendarmes à nos policiers
qui tous les jours sont sur le terrain
nos forces d'incendies et de secours
aussi bien entendu en fin de compte
cette loi ce projet de loi il est fait
pour eux il est fait pour eux et j'en
suis d'autant plus fier car c'était la
première des propositions de la
commission d'enquête parlementaire sur
les forces de sécurité dont j'étais le
rapporteur première des 27 propositions
créées une loi d'orientation pour que
justement demain nos policiers nos
gendarmes puissent voir plus clair
puisse voir à long terme sur leur budget
et finalement ce environ 15 milliards
d'euros 15 milliards d'euros sur 50 qui
serviront un investissement massif
humain bien sûr je pense au 8500
recrutements qui vont qui vont avoir
lieu un investissement pour les
territoires plus de 200 brigades de
gendarmerie et en fin de compte c'est
continuer ce maillage déjà existant mais
continuer ce mariage de nos gendarmerie
dans nos territoires les plus ruraux
mais c'est aussi se mettre à la page sur
les nous de vos défis qui nous attendent
bien entendu la prise en compte de la
crypto monnaie extrêmement importante
aujourd'hui les délinquants ne payent
plus forcément au coin de la rue avec de
l'espèce mais on constate de plus en
plus une crypto-monnaie galopante
compliqué à suivre et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que l'investissement qui est mis
dans toute cette partie cyber au
ministère de l'Intérieur servira à
contrecarrer cette criminalité du XXIe
siècle
continuer aussi avec dans les nouveaux
défis avec ces augmentations sur la
partie cyber et notamment la lutte su
contre les cyberattaques je crois que
nous avons tous toutes et tous été
victime de tentative de rançon et les
moyens qui vont être mis dans la police
et dans la gendarmerie lutter justement
contre ces attaques cyber montre bien
que nous sommes dans l'actualité
l'article 14 extrêmement important de
toutes les auditions que nous avons pu
avoir je me souviens des policiers des
gendarmes qui nous demandaient d'alléger
la procédure pénale de la léger car il
est simple lorsque l'on va lorsque les
gendarmes ou les policiers vont
constater un tapage nocturne lorsque les
gendarmes et les policiers arrêtent une
personne qui serait en train de dîner et
ben derrière ces quatre cinq heures de
procédure pénale alors qu'en fin de
compte c'est un simple rappel à la loi
et parfois même pas demain avec les
amendes forfaitaire délictuel on va
pouvoir simplifier cette
procédure pénale et en fin de compte
faire confiance et je pense que c'est
l'objet de cet article faire confiance à
nos policiers et à nos gendarmes les
débats qu'on a eu toute la semaine
dernière pendant ces 37 heures de le
débat le but n'était pas de dire si oui
ou non on aimait la police si oui ou non
on était contre la police et la
gendarmerie mais de leur de se demander
aussi si on leur faisait confiance si on
faisait confiance à nos policiers si on
faisait confiance à nos gendarmes et cet
article 14 en donnant des pouvoirs
élargis à la police et à la gendarmerie
montre éprouve que l'on doit leur faire
confiance et que l'on peut leur faire
confiance des avancées dans notre groupe
se félicite aussi pour les territoires
insulaires l'accord avec différents
amendements adoptés aussi bien en
commission sur la collaboration entre la
Sardaigne et la Corse pour les
sapeurs-pompiers mais aussi dans
l'hémicycle entre la entre la Toscane et
la Corse pour la préservation des
espaces naturels des amendements
favorables à Mayotte et aux outre-mer en
fin de compte mes chers collègues le
groupe liotte se félicite de ce texte de
loi
avec un peu plus d'une vingtaine
amendements adoptés et c'est ce qui fera
que nous allons voter ce texte en tout
cas une grande majorité de notre groupe
va voter ce texte déjà parce que le
texte va dans le bon sens mais aussi
surtout parce que la méthode était là et
je tiens à remercier le rapporteur pour
son travail et le ministre et ses
équipes pour le travail pendant cette
semaine dans l'hémistice qui a permis de
co-construire ce texte le groupe
libertin indépendant outre et outre-mer
et territoires votre a donc en faveur de
ce texte je vous remercie mon cher
collègue même approbation du côté de la
droite et de l'extrême droite on
approuve une loi qui durcit les peines
contre les auteurs d'actes délictueux
les députés LR et ceux du rassemblement
national Johanne leur voix à celle de la
majorité tout en critiquant le ministre
de l'Intérieur
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues depuis des
années le rassemblement national
brandissait la sécurité comme la
première des libertés et alerter sur les
gouvernements successifs sur les causes
et les conséquences de l'insécurité
depuis des années le rassemblement
national proposait des solutions
concrètes et des mesures de bon sens
afin de lutter contre l'insécurité et la
délinquance que de temps perdu cette loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur est une petite
avancée pour nos forces de Lord qui
attendaient le renforcement de leurs
moyens depuis si longtemps mais elle
reste insuffisante et incomplète il ne
suffit pas d'injecter de l'argent
monsieur le ministre il faut aussi de la
volonté et de la cohérence politique
finalement cette locmi apparaît plus
comme l'ambition de communication d'un
ministre vous monsieur Darmanin que la
volonté sécurité d'un gouvernement
complètement déconnecté de la réalité
depuis des années vos yeux sont restés
permet face à des situations de notre
pays mais si face à l'évidence un oeil
c'est 30 ouvert l'autre restera
définitivement fermée car cette loi de
programmation ne sera efficace qu'avec
une justice réformée qui mettra fin au
laxisme judiciaire monsieur le ministre
je vous le redis votre ambition
sécuritaire sera balayée par le garde
des sceaux en même temps macroniste
tombe face à la réalité et vous nous
donnez le plus beau des exemples le 10
novembre dernier vous indiquez que la
France allait accueillir le bateau
Océane Viking et que je cite les
personnes ne relevant pas du droit au
séjour et d'asile sur notre territoire
feront l'objet de procédure
d'éloignement sans délai vendredi
dernier la Cour d'appel
d'Aix-en-Provence a annoncé la remise en
liberté de la quasi-totalité d'entre eux
faute de temps et de moyens pour la
justice
après le fiasco du Stade de France après
le fiasco du Stade de France où l'on
apprenait votre mensonge concernant les
supporters anglais après le fiasco de la
fuite de l'imam volatilisé qui
soulignait l'impuissance de l'État voici
maintenant le fiasco de l'Océane Viking
où vous envoyez un message d'accueil à
tous ceux qui voudraient venir en France
aujourd'hui les migrants et les mafia de
passeurs du monde entier connaissent
l'incapacité française à lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine c'est l'aveu
de vos faiblesses judiciaires juridiques
mais surtout de votre manque de volonté
et de cohérence politique vous nous
parlez constamment de sobriété
énergétique mais quand allez-vous mettre
en oeuvre enfin à la sobriété migratoire
dois-je vous rappeler que nos prisons
françaises sont peuplées d'un quart
d'étranger ce que Marine Le Pen
dénonçait depuis 20 ans l'UMPS le pire
de la gauche et le pire de la droite
rassembler ensemble vos gants vers on ne
sait quelle horizon telle la dernière
phase d'un système à bout souffle alors
que si le rassemblement national était
au pouvoir notre gouvernement serait
cohérent de beaux garde des sceaux tous
serait ferme sur le respect de nos lois
ferme sur la publication réelle des
peines ferme pour accomplir pleinement
le travail des forces de l'ordre ferme
en demandant des peines exemplaires et
dissuasives ferme en supprimant les
aménagements de peine pour les atteintes
aux personnes fermes sur l'immigration
ferme en expliquant en expulsant les
prêtres les étrangers qui peuplent nos
prisons cette fermeté les Français la
réclame
cette loi de programmation ne sera pas
également assez efficace car vous
n’armez pas suffisamment nos forces de
l'ordre pour faire face à l'insécurité
où est dans cette loi à la présomption
de légitime défense sans demander par
les forces de l'ordre face à ces
manquements le rassemblement national à
proposer tout au long de l'étude de ce
projet de loi des mesures concrètes
grâce au rassemblement national tous les
mineurs seront protégés contre les
outrages sexistes et la prévention des
suicides au sein des forces de l'ordre
sera au cœur des priorités du ministère
de l'Intérieur face à l'urgence de la
situation nous voterons tous qui pourra
comme le nous faisons depuis le début ce
mandat soutenir nos forces de l'ordre
cette loi reste une petite victoire il
faut le dire idéologique pour le
rassemblement national c'est pourquoi
c'est pourquoi nous voterons pour cette
loi de programmation nous vous trompons
pour car notre seul boussole ce sont les
Français rien que les Français
uniquement que les Français
mais et je conclus en reprenant les mots
que vous avez employés il y a quelques
semaines devant les plus hauts
responsables de nos forces de l'ordre
monsieur le ministre vous dites si
l'émission sont claires elles le sont
luttées contre la criminalité et assurer
la sécurité pour tous ces partout sur
les territoires vous dites que les
moyens sont au rendez-vous mais Monsieur
le Ministre ils le sont surtout avec les
milieux de force de Lord qui servent
avec courage à abnégation vous dites que
les résultats sont mitigés voire moins
oui monsieur le ministre les unes des
médias à l'illustre malheureusement
quotidiennement enfin vous dites c'est
peut-être que le chef qui n'est pas bon
or le chef c'est vous le chef du chef
c'est Madame borne le chef du chef du
chef c'est Monsieur Macron alors
permettez-moi cette question pour
laquelle les Français ont d'ailleurs
déjà répondu et si je suis finalement
c'est un simple mot vous qui n'y était
pas bon
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole
alors
la parole est à Monsieur Yann Boucard
pour le groupe les républicains je vous
demande de respecter le dernier orateur
et de faire silence monsieur Boucard
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
alors
mes chers collègues
monsieur Boucard attendait un instant
que l'hémicycle retrouve son calme pour
que nous puissions vous écouter
avant de voter je
vous remercie monsieur Boucard vous avez
la parole merci madame la Présidente je
vois qu'il me revient comme lors des
débats de Ramdas sérénité dans nos
débats monsieur Miss de l'Intérieur
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues après plus de 40 heures
de débats et l'étude de près de 1200
amendements nous avons terminé vendredi
tard dans la nuit l'examen d'un projet
de loi essentiel la loi d'orientation et
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur essentiel car ce projet de
loi détermine les moyens que nous
représentants du peuple à louer aux
femmes et aux hommes qui risquent chaque
jour leur vie pour assurer la sécurité
des Français essentiel car il détermine
à place que nous accordons à celles et
ceux qui font respecter les lois de la
République à celles et ceux qui
maintiennent l'ordre républicain à nos
policiers et à nos gendarmes je veux
dire au nom du groupe des députés les
républicains qui sont l'honneur de la
République et qu'ils pourront toujours
compter sur notre soutien plan et entier
je sais qu'il est de bon ton de remettre
en cause la légitimité de nos forces de
l'ordre de crier à la bavure à la
moindre occasion je sais que certains
l'extrême gauche de cette hémicycle aime
prétendre que les forces de l'ordre sont
une menace pour les plus précaires dans
notre pays je veux au contraire rappeler
notre conviction que les habitants de
nos quartiers populaires que les
citoyens les plus défavorisés sont ceux
qui ont justement le plus besoin de la
protection de nos policiers de nos
gendarmes je veux dire à ceux qui
mettent sur le même plan la parole d'un
délinquant multirécidiviste et d'une
policière ou d'un gendarme qui revêtit
chaque jour l'uniforme au péril de sa
vie pour défendre la République pour
défendre les Françaises et les Français
qu'ils sont irresponsables et qui nous
trouverons toujours sur leur chemin
alors pour en revenir sur le contenu
précis de cette locmi nous aurions
évidemment souhaité qu'elle aille plus
loin sur la question des moyens humains
financiers pour lutter contre la
délinquance car notre pays connaît
depuis quelques années une accélération
des violences et des atteintes au bien
et aux personnes à ce sujet le
gouvernement et la majorité
présidentielle ont fait preuve
d'angélisme et d'un certain dignité
depuis 2017 si vous avez monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur reconnu
l'accélération de la délinquance et dans
sauvagement d'une partie de la
population vous avez immédiatement été
contredis par le garde des sceaux pour
qui le sentiment d'insécurité est pire
que la sécurité elle-même et qui croyait
nécessaire d'ajouter que le sentiment
d'insécurité et de l'ordre du fantasme
c'est en même temps symbolise d'ailleurs
ce qui nous pose problème dans cette
locmi ou le texte proposé par le
gouvernement accorde des moyens
supplémentaires nécessaires à nos forces
de l'ordre mais n'a pas permis au
parlementaire d'agir sur la réponse
pénale c'est en ce sens que nous
voulions enfin instauré des peines
minimales de prison les fameuses peines
plancher à l'égard des personnes
reconnues coupables d'un crime ou d'un
délit commis contre ceux qui nous
projettent protège c'est à dire nos
gendarmes nos policiers nos militaires
nos sapeurs-pompiers ou encore nos
douaniers ces agressions sont intoléra
mais nous amendements ce sens ont été
jugés recevables en raison de
l'appréciation étroite de l'article 45
et une imprimé en constitution et nous
le regrettons comme lors de la
discussion générale s'agissant de la
question des moyens nous saluons la
hausse des crédits de 15 milliards
d'euros sur 50 et le recrutement de 8500
forces de l'ordre supplémentaires si un
amendement du Gouvernement fin de texte
est venu préciser la ventilation de ses
crédits qui nous avait fait défauts lors
de l'examen des articles nous serons
monsieur le ministre particulièrement
vigilant sur l'affectation de ses moyens
car les besoins sont là pour ne prendre
l'exemple que de la rénovation des
bâtiments publics du ministère le budget
qui lui a loué nous paraît insuffisant
80% des casernes gendarmerie ont plus de
25 ans un commissariat sur 4 et vétuste
sont l'IGPN nous devons garantir de
bonnes conditions de travail à nos
forces de l'ordre et les moyens alloués
dans cette locmi s'ils sont nécessaires
ne sont pas encore suffisants vous
l'aurez constaté monsieur le ministre si
nous pensons que cette locmi va dans le
bon sens nous pensons aussi qu'elle
pourrait aller plus loin mais nous
reconnaissons les avancées qu'elles
comportent et nous avons souhaité être
constructifs pour l'enrichir à ce titre
je salue l'adoption en commission des
lois de l'amendement portée par notre
collègue erikiotti qui prévoit
l'augmentation des places en centre de
rétention administrative pour établir à
3000 contre 1859 aujourd'hui c'est notre
pays expulse moins de 8% des étrangers
en situation irrégulière visée par une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français cette proportion augmente à
plus de 40 % lorsqu'ils sont placés en
crasse ce qui prouve l'efficacité de
cette mesure je salue également
l'adoption en séance des amendements que
je portais au nom du groupe les
républicains pour élargir le champ des
délits concernés par l'établissement
d'une amende forfaitaire délictuelle
certes nous préférerions que chaque
délinquant soit visé par une procédure
judiciaire mais les déliques nous avons
ajouté à la liste de ce couvert par la
FD ne sont jamais sanctionnés et il nous
semble essentiel d'en finir avec
l'impunité au sujet de ces infractions
qui pourrissent la vie de nos
concitoyens cela concerne un titre
d'exemple le délit de vente à la
sauvette celui de port s'en motif
légitime d'armes blanches ou encore
l'introduction de boissons alcoolisées
dans les stades enfin pour donner les
moyens à cet outil de fonctionner au
regard notamment du faible taux de
recouvrement des AFD nous avons
également obtenu qu'une réflexion soit
menée sur la possibilité d'instaurer une
saisie sur salaire si la personne qui a
commis cette infraction refuse de payer
son amende je suis par ailleurs très
satisfait de l'adoption à l'unanimité de
mon amendement prévoir une circonstance
aggravante en cas d'outrage sexy sous
sexuel commis sur un mineur quelle que
soit son âge car la protection de
l'enfance est et restera toujours une
priorité de notre groupe vous l'aurez
compris monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous n'avons pas souhaité
faire obstruction à cette Lemmy qui est
nécessaire mais nous avons été forces de
proposition pour l'améliorer
considérablement car nous considérons
nous car nous considérons que son
contenu n'était pas suffisant lorsqu'il
nous a été présenté de même nous serons
extrêmement vigilants à l'avenir
s'agissant d'utilisation des moyens qui
sont contenus et de la bonne réaction de
ceci nos forces de l'ordre méritent
mieux que des paroles une mairie des
actes les députés les républicains
seront comme toujours du côté de ce qui
agissent et nous voterons donc pour
cette loi de rotation programmation de
mystère voilà pour les positions des 10
groupes représentés dans l'hémicycle et
c'est l'heure du vote
donc je vais donc mettre au bois le
projet de loi je vous demande de bien
vouloir
regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scruteur votant 570
exprimé 535 majorité 268 pour 419 contre
116 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
monsieur le ministre et c'est l'usage
après le vote le ministre prend la
parole Gérard Darmanin se félicite du
bon esprit qui anime les débats à
l'Assemblée nationale sur le vote de sa
loi
[Applaudissements]
bien madame
un peu de silence merci madame la
Présidente je voudrais tout d'abord
remercier monsieur le rapporteur qui a
fait un excellent travail avec vous
et dire à monsieur le rapporteur et à
son excellent travail que c'est
notamment grâce à lui et aux orateurs de
chaque groupe qu'on a pu adopter
effectivement 170 à un moment donc 40 %
de l'opposition Simon le site
d'ouverture du gouvernement du
rapporteur et je veux dire des
amendements adoptés par tous les groupes
même lorsque ceci dès le début de la
discussion générale évoqué qu'il ne
voterait pas le texte que nous
présentons je vous remercie évidemment
les parlementaires qui ont participé à
ce débat et ça lui est très profondément
les policiers les gendarmes les pompiers
les agents de préfecture
qui font un travail formidable
et à la demande du Président de la
République désormais ont un texte à la
hauteur de leurs moyens pour protéger
les Français merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre quelques
jours plus tard l'Assemblée nationale a
définitivement adopté la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur après un accord
avec les sénateurs insiste termine cette
séance vous pouvez la revoir sur la
chaîne Youtube de LCP et sur LCP.fr à
bientôt même lieu même heure